did you see the guy that won the
Powerball no so he he won $2 billion
right remember when like we were all
playing it or whatever the last like
massive jackpot yeah he won 2 billion he
took the lump sum for 950 million or
something like that only yeah I know and
is that with tax yeah but I thought with
the lump sum you also get less not
because of tax but because they like
it's like their tax so he took the lump
sum so he took the lump sum $997 million
okay and uh he just bought his third
house so he bought a $25 million house
first Y and then he bought like some
like6 million house somewhere else and
then he just bought I think a $75
million house okay moving fast yeah I
mean this man is going to go
broke do you know what's the property
tax on $100 million in real estate uh
annually five million what is it 5% or
something yeah I was gonna I thought it
like more like this is the ballpark I
was thinking
one 1% what does property tax on $100
million in
property one so that that would be $1
million a year yep yep I thought
property tax was like way more than
that there's other [__] that makes it
more expensive yeah but and then also
like maintenance yeah maintenance is the
big one yeah so I believe the statistics
are pretty high that big Winners like
this I think a lot of them
end up uh looking down the
barrel damn
okay sorry had to kid cudy that a little
bit jeez Louise from what I remember I
believe the statistic is oh house I
think this guy's going to kill
himself you know here it is $47 million
mansion sorry not
75 but this
house was owned by some crazy plastic
surgeon yeah I'm pretty sure I did a
video on a real estate tour of this
house because he had a nft like Museum
in it oh sick he had I think it's this
house so then his nfts became worth zero
so he had to sell it yeah the surgeon
was I mean the guy that's selling this
house is [__] batshit insane I'm
pretty sure yeah hey um to all those
crypto dudes a couple years ago that
were calling us haters and we don't
understand the future and web 3
and we're idiots can you explain where
all the value in those nfts
went I'm just curious yeah that's the
same house right there he is yeah so he
had like a DJ booth that like comes out
of the floor and [__] like that which is
totally the stupidest [__] thing in
the world like it's like in the living
room right like you walk in the front
door and there's like a DJ booth that
like comes out of the ground but it that
is the most win the lottery guy purchase
ever is is it not yeah this dude that
went from having nothing to having a
billion dollars he's like I need a [__]
[__] nftd guy well yeah I I need a DJ
booth that comes out of the [__]
ground I would have thought the most
when the lottery guy move is if like he
just bought a $900 million
house yeah he buys the one whatever that
[__] they're like no no you don't want
to do that he's like like why it's I
have the money I have 997 this is
nine I more than can pay for this yeah
I've got it dude we'll check in on this
guy remind me one
year Remind me five
years oh you get gold for that thanks
dude thank you kind
stranger you get like gold yeah thank
you man that's a that's a face of a dude
that's about to go out and buy a $50
million that's the face of a yeah his
face is like you know what I'm about to
do
it do I'm about to have a DJ boo he's
like I'm buying a $50 million house I'm
doing 50 million in cocaine and I'm
dying tomorrow bro tomorrow you think
I'm keeping this [__] yeah right I love
that everyone also is like the first
rule when you win the lottery is don't
tell anyone yeah and this this
[__] has got the paparazzi
outside the that's the thing man he's
like it's Edwin Castro
baby remember my
name he's like no about to get [__] up
imagine he's just he just gets up to the
little booth he's like remember this
look remember this face cuz it's all
going away I'm getting [__] lipo I'm
getting a trainer I'm getting my
hairline uh changed yeah I'm getting jaw
surgery I'm not going to be the same
Edwin dude lose my number to my wife
lose my number lose my number it's a new
guy now yeah I'm rich Edwin I'm rich
Edwin he's just [__] yeah he comes back
like next year just bogged
out B dude the search the plastic
surgeon that used to own that house a
celebrity btox doctor blew his Budget on
an La Mega Mansion now he's facing
bankruptcy why would you do that cuz
people in LA are [__] weird yeah they
are yeah um did you not hear about the
nft gallery yeah did you not hear when I
said that you know what where are your
nfts right now yeah are they up in a
gallery or they sitting in a [__]
rainbow wallet on your phone I don't
know man tell me how that bankruptcy
filing is
going you're moving on to the next
chapter of your life buddy 11 oh [__] oh
[__] okay I see it oh [__] okay if
you're listening on audio imagine like
imagine looking at a person but you're
not sure if they're
cake like I think I could eat this guy
based on the texture of his
this Dude Looks Like fondant are you
[__] with
me there he is with uh what's his name
again oh the guy with the sex cult let
the Lord be with you no that's Jared
Leto that's not Jared Leto who's that
this is Scott dick one of the oh
Kardashians man what a last name dude he
looks like like the side of a
Schlotzsky's cup or something you know
just a weird artistic rendition of a
person
you know what I
mean like he looks like he's drawn in
like without lifting the pen you know
like just so
weird a th% yeah yeah man so this this
is La
man the city does things to people I
truly and that's what so that's what
Edwin Castro is going to look like yeah
soon yeah is that dude
yeah yeah I bought your get like a
special can I get like friends rate yeah
can I get homies right yeah
bro caked out yeah Caked Up on the face
women get the BBL men get the face BBL
yeah yeah bro why would you buy a $25
million house and then a $45 million
house why would you do
that maybe you needs like house for the
dogs for the dogs for all the dogs yeah
for his pets yeah yeah his feet he's got
his Barefoot house shoe
house this is my dog house yeah this is
my shoe house yeah I wear shoes in this
one I know like the dogs breathing this
one got special tile they cool off the
the dog cool off the old
dogs